I'm intro this is officer McCord we got  a 1030 woman I need you to run a plate  flash is the fastest guy in there you  can run the plate like that wait they're  all slots are you saying it because he's  a sloth he can't be fast flash flash  under guard - buddy it's nice to see you  nice to see you hmm - hmm officer judy  hopps zpd how are you I am doing fine  well what hang in there can I do well I  was hoping you could run a pool you well  I was hoping you today  well I was hoping you could run a play  for us we are in a really big hurry  what's the plate - 9 T number - 9 th D 0  3 - 9 t HD 0 3 h d0 3 b 0 3 0 3 a flash  one of your a joke no sure mm-hmm  what do you call a three humped camel I  don't know pregnant  yes honey but we please just focus on  this a way my way Priscilla oh yes  flash what do know you call a three hubs  kill pregnant okay  cream you got it please jump hurry we  got a bigger rush hour it it's night to  find at least does fit munch my - Oh  bleep